je vais mettre de dos non de biais parce
que sinon j'ai peur
et maintenant le meilleur de Gaspard
Proust
baccalauréat la discipline reste la
philo avec ce truc le travail permet-il
de prendre conscience de soi ah non il y
a qu'à voir Zahia elle a déclaré que son
métier c'était courtisane et non pas
prostitué
[Applaudissements]
la différence entre une prostituée et
une courtisane selon Wikipédia c'est
qu'elles sont plus les traits et elles
vivaient avec des écrivains des artistes
des aristocrates ah oui c'est vrai que
quand tu vois le sa clientèle c'est pile
dans la définition
[Applaudissements]
politique et morale Bernard Tapie il est
fort c'est mon héros quoi ce mec c'est
vraiment c'est le seul type qui est
capable d'arriver en garde à vue et de
se débrouiller pour qu'on inculpe aussi
son avocat
il se balade toujours avec un avocat de
secours on sait jamais c'est
un habitué à ce stade tapis il doit
avoir un double des clés de sa cellule
c'est
sport à faire Jalabert c'est terrible ce
qui arrive est-ce vraiment nécessaire
d'accabler un type dont le palmarès
prouve que le dopage ne marche pas
[Applaudissements]
non mais il a gagné quatre étapes du
tour dans sa vie quand on a dû lui
injecter un placebo c'est pas possible
alors moi j'ai vu son témoignage alors
c'est les aveux à la jalabère quoi en
terme de défense virant qu'à côté c'est
mettre Vergès c'était vraiment le type
ouais bon j'arrivais dans la roulotte on
me faisait des soins des soins c'est le
type il rentre dans la caravane il
montre un genou écorché on va dire non
non on va pas prendre de risques qu'on
va faire deux piqûres une transfusion
comme ça sera bien désinfecté tu sais
t'inquiète pas d'ailleurs cette année on
nous promet pas de dopage pas de dopage
de toute façon il y a pas il y a pas
besoin qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que le
Tour de France c'est quoi 3400 km 21
étapes de jours de repos six étapes de
montagne une moyenne de 40 km/h en
général tu prends deux gouttes d'huile
essentielle le matin c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
bon coin une famille Rome a vendu son
gamin 15000 euros
il a été rendu il a été rendu belle
opération avec les portefeuilles ramenés
la famille a fait une plus-value de 5000
euros
mariage gay un maire refuse de marier
des gays je vois pas pourquoi on le
critique c'est quand même vachement
gentil de sa part de pas vouloir gâcher
la fête
il va leur dire quoi bon ben Robert
est-ce que vous voulez vraiment prendre
pour époux s'il vient s'il vient c'est
ça excusez-moi je peux vous appeler
Sylvie parce que sinon on va pas
maintenant vous pouvez vous serrer enfin
vous
je vais mettre de dos non de biais parce
que sinon j'ai peur
enfin je trouve que c'est vraiment un
axe citoyen de passer les bras le
mariage quand on en a pas les moyens
politiques toujours alors Hollande a
réagi avec autorité il a viré Delphine
bateau moi bateau je l'aimais bien
j'aimais bien ça elle m'a vachement
sensibilisé au
parce qu'en fait chez moi il y a il y a
une poubelle verte c'est une poubelle
noire bon il y en a une autre avec un
trou où ça fait scling de enfin jamais
compris à quoi ça servait et jusque là
je pensais qu'on pouvait mettre que des
trucs verts dans la poubelle verte
mais en fait mais en fait non parce que
Delphine bateau elle a ma sensibilisé
quoi
alors elle a été remplacée par Philippe
Martin ouais c'est un type très
c'est qui en fait
[Musique]
Egypte alors apparemment maintenant le
printemps arabe c'est une fois par an
bah ça se comprend quand on sait qu'il y
a eu à peu près 100 agressions sexuelles
en quelques jours place tarir pourquoi
arrêter de manifester c'est en fait la
place derrière c'est devenu un club
échangiste en plein air c'est
plus une révolution démocratique c'est
sexuelle c'est jouir sans entrave sous
le ni câble à tout enfin c'est très
alors résultat les manifestants ont été
entendus c'est-à-dire que l'armée a
dégagé le président Morsi président qui
était à 32% d'opinions positives tu vois
c'est à ce genre de détails qu'on
remarque que l'armée française est
complètement sclérosée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Front national Marine a perdu son
immunité parce que elle a parlé
d'occupation pour désigner des prières
de rue bon les prières de rue c'est vrai
que c'est un sujet qui excite les gens
c'est
moi j'ai un copain homo qui a un appart
juste au dessus de la rue en question tu
étais ravi quoi à chaque fois qu'il y
avait une prière de rue il allait jamais
à la terrasse sans son rouleau de
sopalin
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu